ces cocktails n'y a pas de combat
la fédération de russie mène des
exercices tactiques dans la zone de ces
territoires ddt
nous sommes dans l'oblast de rostov
région russe frontalière de l'ukraine et
bien que les explosions se font entendre
au loin
les habitants ne semble pas inquiété par
la guerre qui a lieu à leur porte
je ne pense pas qu'il s'agisse d'un
conflit à grande échelle
j'en doute vraiment
n'est ce pas il ya une injustice en
ukraine
les nazis sont au pouvoir
depuis des mois les médias d'état russe
développe le même récit pour justifier
l'invasion de l'ukraine
les dirigeants ukrainiens sont dépeints
comme des nazis et des marionnettes de
l'ouest les troupes russes comme des
libérateurs intervenant pour empêcher un
prétendu génocide bien que le kremlin
est fourni aucune preuve pour étayer ses
accusations
de nombreux russes sont convaincus que
poutine mène une guerre défensive pour
protéger la russie libéré l'ukraine
d'autres expriment leur sympathie et
compassion pour leurs voisins ukrainiens
n'a pas nié mais l'essentiel c'est de
comprendre que ce n'est pas la faute des
civils
c'est une guerre de politiciens et les
civils ne font que souffrir de ce qui se
passe dans le pays
défier le récit officiel voilà à quoi ce
risque les milliers de manifestants qui
descendent dans les rues pour protester
contre l'invasion de l'ukraine on y
déplore plus de 1700 arrestation signe
que les autorités russes restent
déterminés à faire taire les sceptiques